on commence
dépasser les 5 minutes c'est pas bien
on n'a pas les noms des deux autres
personnes
et voilà
bonjour
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
notre commission d'enquête entend
aujourd'hui l'agence nationale de santé
publique plus connue sur le nom de santé
publique France
et plus connu encore depuis la crise de
la covid
c'est un établissement public
relevant de la tutelle du ministère de
la Santé
l'agence a été créée en 2016 et s'est vu
confié par la loi plusieurs missions en
lien direct ou indirect avec l'objet de
nos travaux d'abord la surveillance
épidémiologique et la veille sanitaire
pour observer l'état de santé de la
population française et anticipée les
risques ensuite la prévention matière de
santé publique la promotion de la santé
et l'éducation à la santé
enfin la préparation et la réponse aux
menaces alertes des crises sanitaires
en particulier la loi prévoit je cite
que la chance assure pour le compte de
l'État la gestion de stocks de produits
équipement et matériels ainsi que de
services nécessaires à la protection des
populations face aux menaces sanitaires
graves
vous avez été concerné notamment au
niveau de la distribution des vaccins en
ce qui concerne les anesthésies qui ont
fait défaut en urgence en avril 2020
mais aussi sur une part de gestion des
masques qui ensuite été décentralisées
voilà et donc dans vos missions
vous avez aussi celle d'agir face aux
risques pour l'accès au traitement donc
ce qui était le cas pour pour les
anesthésiques au cours des dernières
années il a beaucoup pété question de
l'action de santé publique France en
lien avec la pandémie de covid-19 mais
nous souhaiterions aujourd'hui mieux
comprendre quel rôle l'agence peut jouer
dans l'anticipation et la résorption des
tensions d'approvisionnement en effet
les pénuries constituent indéniablement
bien que de manière peut-être plus
diffuse et moins visible que les
pandémies une menace sanitaire qui
impacte très directement la santé des
Françaises et des Français quel rôle
pourrait être le rôle de santé publique
France non plus en situation
exceptionnelle mais dans le cadre du
fonctionnement courant mais défaillant
défaillants et s'aggravant de la chaîne
du médicament en clair l'agence
dispose-t-elle de capacités pour le
faire et de quels moyens financier
aurait-elle besoin pour éventuellement
remplir cette mission par exemple pour
garantir l'équité territoriales de
l'approvisionnement en médicament
j'ajouterai à ces moyens financiers et
aux besoins de la mission
quels moyens aurait-elle aussi de
pouvoir travailler en relation avec les
structures déjà existantes qui traitent
déjà chacune
séparément de cette question de la
pénurie de médicaments nous accueillons
donc aujourd'hui madame Caroline
semaille Directrice Générale de Santé
Publique France poste que vous occupez
depuis le mois de février dernier
excusez-moi un petit problème de nom
et également vous êtes accompagné par
Monsieur Stéphane costaglioli le
directeur alerté-crise et Madame Halima
Marie Mali quitté directrice de cabinet
pour cette audition d'une durée
d'environ une heure et demie nous
voulons un peu moins d'une heure et
demie nous vous laisserons tout d'abord
la parole pour un propos très concret de
moins de 10 minutes puis madame Laurence
Cohen rapporter heureux de notre
commission d'enquête vous posera des
questions
précises une première salle de question
et ensuite je donnerai la parole à mes
collègues pour des questions
complémentaires
exactement
je précise que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission dans
quête et passible des peines prévues aux
articles 434 13 434 14 et 434 15 du code
pénal je vous invite chacun à votre tour
à prêter serment de dire toutes les
vérités rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je jure madame
semaille
vous pouvez me répéter juste le début
et Madame Marie Mali quitté je le jure
je vous remercie et je vous donne la
parole pour environ 10 minutes
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc je vous remercie tout
d'abord d'avoir souhaité auditionné
stante et publique France dans le cas de
vos travaux sur la pénurie des
médicaments vous l'avez dit en
introduction santé publique France a été
créé en 2016 pour assurer la
surveillance de l'état de santé la
population lancer l'alerte répondre aux
besoins d'environnement favorable à la
santé par la prévention et concevoir des
stratégies de réponses de santé publique
notamment en situation sanitaire
exceptionnelle
nos missions concernent ainsi pour le
compte de l'État la réponse en soutien
au système des soins face aux menaces
sanitaires graves notamment aux
mobilisant la réserve sanitaire et
l'établissement pharmaceutique qui est
chargé de la Constitution et de la
gestion des stocks stratégiques des
produits de santé
la mission de santé publique France dans
ce domaine est défini par l'article
l1413-4 du code de la santé publique qui
prévoit je cite à la demande du ministre
chargé de la santé l'agence procède à
l'acquisition la fabrication
l'importation le stockage le transport
la distribution et l'exportation des
produits et services nécessaires à la
protection de la population face au
menaces sanitaires graves l'agence
assure dans les mêmes conditions leur
renouvellement pour ce faire santé
publique France dispose donc d'un
établissement pharmaceutique les stocks
stratégiques de l'État et nous y
reviendrons sont définies par la
circulaire interministérielle du 26
septembre 2013 relative à l'élaboration
du Plan zonal de mobilisation des
ressources sanitaires les stocks
stratégiques permettent à l'état de
maintenir une capacité d'intervention en
renfort pour répondre à des événements
de grande ampleur épidémiques chimiques
ou radio nucléaires accidentelles ou
terroriste
la constitution des stocks stratégiques
nationaux en produits de santé c'est
développer depuis 2001 puis au fur et à
mesure de l'émergence des risques
notamment infectieux terroriste
industriel et pour soutenir
l'application des plans gouvernementaux
pandémie grippales 2011 et bola 2014
plan national de réponse à un accident
nucléaire ou radiologique majeur 2014
2014 plan NRBC 2016 il peut s'agir
notamment de stocks
d'antibiotiques de vaccin de dispositifs
médicaux de petits matériels de
consommables ou d'équipement de
protection individuel
dans le cadre des moyens de l'État face
à des situations exceptionnelle c'est
stocks stratégiques viennent en
complément des stocks tactiques qui sont
eux positionnés auprès des
établissements de santé sur l'ensemble
des territoires l'acquisition et la
maintenance de ces stocks tactiques sont
financés par les établissements de santé
ils sont conditionnés sous forme de mal
contenant par exemple des antidotes des
solutions de remplissage des
respirateurs etc pour répondre aux
premières urgences
les stocks stratégiques quant à eux ne
sont en principe pas mobilisés en
première intention à l'exception
évidemment de certains antidotes on
pourrait y revenir antitoxines
diphthériques antitoxines botulique ce
dispositif a double étage donc stock
stratégique et tactique bien évidemment
en complément d'une stratégie plus
globale de sécurisation des
approvisionnements au niveau national et
puis également au niveau européen
un cadre de constitution et d'emplois
des stocks stratégiques donc je parle
bien de la Déstock stratégique non pas
des stocks tactiques de l'État a été
arrêté en 2017 il est actuellement en
cours de révision pour intégrer
notamment le retour d'expérience de la
gestion de la crise covid 2019 et
évidemment santé publique France
contribue à la révision de ce cadre
le ministère chargé de la santé nous
adressent chaque année une instruction
de programmation indiquant la nature et
les quantités de contre-mesure à
acquérir sur la base des recommandations
d'autorité de santé au Conseil de la
santé publique ou d'autres agences
d'expertise il RSN ASN anses INERIS
évidemment la NSM est également
régulièrement consultée en ce qui
concerne tout ce qui est efficacité et
sécurité des produits de santé
les acquisitions se font dans le rêve
des règles de la des règles de la
commande publique il s'agit de marcher
public nationaux qui s'insère dans une
démarche européenne je pense notamment
ce qui s'est passé pour la grippe
pandémique ou la vaccination covid
certaines acquisitions peuvent également
s'effectuer auprès de la Pharmacie
centrale des armées pour certaines
spécialités
pour assurer l'opérationnalité de ses
stocks santé publique France propose et
met en œuvre des schémas de stockage et
de distribution logistique
en termes de stockage le schéma
directeur repose sur une plateforme
nationale appartement en propre à santé
publique France et sur des plateformes à
compétences nationales ozonale opéré par
des prestataires privés sélectionnés par
l'agence au terme du procédure d'appel
d'offres
les spécificités des territoires
d'outre-mer ont été prises en compte
évidemment en créant des plateformes de
proximité en Martinique Guadeloupe
Guyane Saint-Martin Mayotte et à la
Réunion
les produits doivent être mobilisés en
cas d'urgence à partir des plateformes
en moins de 4 heures en tout point du
territoire et l'acheminement doit être
réalisé en moins de 12 heures pour
garantir de telles délais l'entrepôt
doit être accessible 24/24 7 jours sur 7
en complément de ces plateformes zonales
et nationales santé publique France
appui sur le réseau des grossistes
répartiteurs par exemple pour le
stockage et la distribution de l'iode
en termes de schéma logistique les
schémas sont adaptés à chaque situation
nombre de points de livraison nombre de
spécialités concernées quantités
contraintes etc liées aux produits
il est important de noter que les stocks
stratégiques ne sont pas uniquement
composées de stocks physiques
c'est-à-dire qu'il existe aussi ce qu'on
appelle des marchés de réservation de
capacités de production et donc la
possibilité de disposer de stocks
tournant gérés par les fournisseurs on
pense notamment à ce qui s'est passé
pour le curare
alors quels sont les enjeux pour la
constitution des stocks stratégiques
alors évidemment en premier lieu c'est
le choix des produits pour lequel un
stock stratégique doit être constitué en
prenant en compte évidemment la
cartographie des risques sanitaires la
disponibilité des contre-mesures et puis
un deuxième enjeu très important c'est
l'analyse et la mise en oeuvre des
modalités d'acquisition de stockage de
distribution de ces produits
l'agence veille également sur les
signalements de tension sur certains
médicaments vous avez cité la
problématique de pénurie nous y sommes
aussi évidemment très très soucieux qui
relèvent donc les tensions qui relèvent
des stocks stratégiques en lien avec la
NSM et la DGS et on échange aussi avec
nos fournisseurs dès lors que nous avons
la notion d'une tension aussi bien
d'ailleurs sur la matière première qui
est nécessaire à la fabrication ou sur
la fabrication elle-même
dans la mesure du mieux possible
l'agence s'efforce également de
s'appuyer sur plusieurs fournisseurs
pour répartir les risques mais certaines
spécialités ne sont produites que par un
nombre restreint de laboratoire voire
sans en situation de monopole je pense
aux antidotes notamment
santé publique France pourrait-il se
substituer en cas de pénurie de certains
médicaments
si le code de la santé publique prévoit
que l'agence puisse constituer des
stocks en cas de pénurie ou de risques
de rupture d'approvisionnement ces
dispositions sont mobilisables en cas de
menace sanitaires graves et de façon
temporaire
de plus il faut avoir en tête que tout
intervention sur des marchés déjà tendus
doivent être évalués avec précaution
pour ne pas déstabiliser un peu plus le
marché cette analyse est réalisée par le
ministère qui est le donneur d'ordre de
santé publique France
santé publique France n'a pas vocation à
se substituer évidemment aux obligations
des industriels qui doivent disposer
d'un stock de sécurité minimale de deux
mois pour tous les
items les médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeur afin d'anticiper
les risques de rupture de stock
en outre la logistique pharmaceutique
étatique est à activer de manière
exceptionnelle elle ne peut assurer
durablement des missions qui incombe à
des réseaux éprouvés conçu pour une
distribution de masse sur un large
réseau alors jusque au niveau officinal
en revanche lorsque la rupture est
avérée pour des produits spécifiques il
peut être envisagé que l'État se
substitue au marché cela s'est produit
dans des circonstances exceptionnelles
et vous les connaissez celui des
médicaments curare hypnotiques en plein
en pleine crise covid au deuxième second
semestre 2020 quand l'État s'est
substitué au marché santé publique
France a alors eu le monopole
d'acquisition des curare des hypnotiques
et devenu l'acquéreur exclusif pour le
compte de l'état de ces produits auprès
de nombreux laboratoires pharmaceutiques
et filiales françaises donc pendant la
crise afin d'assurer une répartition
équitable de ces médicaments entre les
établissements sur l'ensemble du
territoire
notre intervention ne peut donc être
exceptionnelle en cas de menace
sanitaire grave et temporaire
je vous remercie de votre attention et
suis à l'écoute de à votre écoute pour
répondre à vos questions
très bien je vous remercie beaucoup de
ces propos très complets donc je vais
demander proposer à Laurence Cohen de
Madame la rapporteur de de poser sa
première salle de question
oui merci Madame pour vos propos très
très synthétiques
j'aimerais que vous me donniez plus de
d'éléments concernant le fait que santé
publique France possède un établissement
pharmaceutique c'est-à-dire que nous
nous sommes sensibles
enfin à l'état des lieux parce que
c'était important effectivement de le
réactualiser mais éventuellement aux
solutions que nous pourrions apporter
pour aider justement à ce qu'il n'y ait
pas de pénurie de médicaments de rupture
etc donc nous sommes intéressés de
connaître mieux les possibilités
finalement de l'État donc quand on quand
vous parlez d'un établissement
pharmaceutique est-ce que ça veut dire
que il y a production possible
envisageable de médicaments et si tel
est le cas qu'elles peuvent être les
médicaments et dans quel produit et dans
quel dans quelle situation ça c'est ma
première question deuxième ma deuxième
question santé publique Franck a
bénéficié au cours des dernières années
compte tenues de la crise sanitaire la
crise covid de dotation exceptionnelle
de la part de l'État notamment pour 2020
pour 2021 et pour 2022 et c'était des
sommes qui étaient autour à chaque fois
chaque année de 4 milliards 8 milliards
4,3 milliards et 3,8 milliards au titre
d'ailleurs de la prévention épidémique
et justement de la constitution de stock
stratégique dont vous nous avez parlé
sachant que votre budget annuel et
environ de 200 millions d'euros on voit
bien là que effectivement c'est une
c'est une dotation extrêmement
importante et est-ce que finalement ce
budget exceptionnel a été uniquement
dédié à la lutte contre le covid ou
est-ce qu'il a été utilisé notamment
pour des actions de surveillance
sanitaire en matière d'accès aux
médicaments ou justement de résorption
des pénuries et à ce moment là si tel
est le cas est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des éléments sur sur ces actions
mais quand on voit les sommes qui ont
été allouées est-ce qu'on peut
finalement se dire que votre budget
le budget on va dire classique de
l'agence et particulièrement sous-évalué
parce que effectivement 200 millions 4
milliards ça fait quand même un grand un
grand Delta donc ça c'était ma première
ma première question
dans votre mission de veille sanitaire
et de prévention des risques sanitaires
ça c'est ma deuxième question comment
est-ce que vous prenez en compte l'enjeu
de l'approvisionnement des médicaments
vous l'avez un petit peu dit mais ce
serait intéressant que nous ayons des
précisions par exemple sur le suivi de
l'accès des Françaises et des Français
aux médicaments notamment justement
parce que vous avez insisté par rapport
aux plateformes donc de proximité
géographique etc est-ce que vous avez la
possibilité de se suivi pour voir si ce
que vous avez pu
anticiper finalement s'avère efficace ou
est-ce qu'il faudrait modifier les
choses et en fait est-ce qu'il y a un
angle mort de la veille sanitaire en
France ce qui appellerait à finalement
renforcé renforcer vos missions alors je
vous dis tout de suite que
personnellement je fais partie des
parlementaires et nous sommes plusieurs
autour de cette table à ne pas envisager
un élargissement des missions d'une
agence sans lui en procurer les moyens
financiers humains parce que sinon c'est
un petit peu facile je ferme la
parenthèse troisième question au cours
des des auditions précédentes nous avons
été alertés par les les industriels du
secteur qui nous ont indiqué qu'une
partie des pénuries s'expliquerait ils
ont été plus catégoriques que moi mais
s'expliquerait par l'incapacité des
pouvoirs publics à anticiper et
notamment à informer les producteurs des
besoins en médicaments alors est-ce que
vous partagez cette ce constat puisque
en fait si j'ai bien compris santé
publique France est justement chargé de
réaliser les prévisions épidémiologiques
donc comment est-ce que vous répondez à
ces critiques est-ce qu'il y a là encore
des failles des manques et des choses
évidemment à améliorer ma quatrième
question c'est concernant un rapport
récent de la Cour des comptes qui a été
d'ailleurs demandé par le par le Sénat
et qui qui estimait donc il faudrait
serait pertinent on va dire d'élargir
les facultés d'auto saisine de santé
publique France notamment en matière
donc de gestion des crises sanitaires
pour que cette agence soit plus réactive
et plus voilà plus réactive et plus
autonome est-ce que vous pensez que
cette
préconisation du Sénat pourrait
effectivement
contribuer à mieux prendre en compte et
mieux traiter les pénuries de
médicaments et enfin ma dernière
question c'est vous l'avez évoqué
extrêmement brièvement ce sont les
relations avec le Centre européen de
Prévention et de Contrôle des Maladies
en matière de prévention des pénuries de
médicaments et des crises sanitaires
donc je pense à la Commission européenne
et je pense également aussi au paquet
pharmaceutique parce que vous savez vous
êtes bien placé pour savoir que ce
paquet pharmaceutique qui était attendu
par tous les pays a été a été à nouveau
retardé que malheureusement ce retard
risque de nous conduire après les
élections européennes
très bien madame la sénatrice merci pour
toutes ces questions extrêmement
pertinentes certaines sont dans notre
champ certaines sont pas dans notre
champ et plutôt dans le champ notamment
de la NSM alors en termes de
d'établissement pharmaceutique donc nous
avons effectivement nous abritons donc
au sein de santé publique France
l'établissement pharmaceutique et
d'ailleurs dans la direction alerté
crise et donc c'est pour ça que Stéphane
m'accompagne et donc il répondra aussi à
un certain nombre de questions pour
je lui passerai donc régulièrement la
parole donc nous avons donc un
établissement pharmaceutique
effectivement vous l'avez souligné nous
avons dans nos missions la gestion
opérationnelle et il y a le mot
fabrication ça ne vous a pas
effectivement échappé qu'il y avait le
mot fabrication alors
très concrètement aujourd'hui
l'établissement pharmaceutique n'a pas
du tout les moyens de fabriquer au sens
fabriqué avec à partir de matières
premières et de fabriquer donc à partir
de matières premières un produit fini
aujourd'hui on ne dispose pas ni des
moyens financiers ni des moyens humains
ni même et là comme je dois jurer je ni
même je pense de sale blanche en fait du
coup de
d'infrastructure qui nous permettrait de
fabriquer des produits finis alors vous
allez me dire mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a ce terme alors il nous a déjà servi
parce que en fait le mot fabrication
tout le monde pense à on prend la
matière première on fait un produit fini
et après on va le libérer dans sur le
marché mais derrière le mois de
fabrication il y a aussi par exemple le
reikiktage et donc ça nous a permis le
fait qu'il y ait le mot fabrication dans
nos missions ça nous a permis très
concrètement dans le cadre des vaccins
variole donc on a utilisé pour la crise
de réétiqueter les vaccins donc voilà ou
à plusieurs reprises on a d'autres
expériences je pense que c'est ça là
essentiellement et en fait le reikiktage
veut dire que c'est ça fait partie des
bonnes pratiques de fabrication parce
que dès lors que on réétique on fait le
reikiktable alors c'est le pharmacien
qui doit libérer le lot donc ça ça fait
partie des bonnes fabriques des bonnes
pratiques de fabrication donc voilà donc
ce terme est important pour nous parce
que ça nous laisse une certaine
flexibilité si on doit réétiqueter
reconditionner par exemple mais en
revanche nous n'avons pas la capacité de
fabriquer et nous nous l'avons jamais
fait
et nous ne sommes pas en mesure de le
faire et quand on voit en face
effectivement les capacités de
production du secteur privé voir
d'autres structures nous ne sommes pas
du tout effectivement une entité qui est
qui est crantée pour pour ce genre de
mission donc ça tu veux compléter sur ce
point-là
si Caroline madame leur rapporteur pour
compléter les propos de notre directrice
générale sur la fabrication l'autre
piste qui peut être envisagée c'est
avoir recours à de la sous-traitance
parce qu'il y a aussi cette possibilité
mais là aussi ça requiert des moyens
supplémentaires notamment pour réaliser
la pharmacovigilance qui peut être qui
peut être associé
donc il y a aussi ce volet là pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur quand on
parle d'établissement pharmaceutique
pour
santé publique France c'est une
quinzaine d'équivalent en plein
permanent donc voilà ça simple chiffre
illustre les moyens permanents à
disposition de l'établissement
pharmaceutique
qui sont à mettre au regard des moyens
qu'ils sont que nous avons en face donc
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas
répondre à toutes les demandes de
souhaiter alors sur le deuxième point
vous avez souligné le budget
effectivement de santé biblique France
qui est donc peut être très très élevé
qui est hors fonction socle nous avons
effectivement certaines années oui des
budgets qui étaient en de l'ordre du
milliard donc effectivement ces budgets
sont vraiment nécessaires pour non pas
les actions de surveillance sanitaire là
c'est budgets très très importants alors
nous avons dans notre budget évidemment
de santé publique France le budget socle
qui est pour les les actions de
surveillance sanitaire mais en tout cas
les budgets quelquefois qu'on pourrait
considérer comme très élevé en tout cas
voilà très très élevé de santé publique
France comparativement à d'autres
agences de sécurité sanitaire sont
vraiment effectivement
fléchés sur l'achat notamment des
vaccins covid ou des vaccins variole
dans le cadre de l'épidémie de mon kpops
le coût de ces vaccins sont extrêmement
élevés puisque les vaccins covides sont
des vaccins ARN et les vaccins variolent
étaient aussi des vaccins assez
complexes et en tout cas très recherchée
au niveau européen donc en termes de
vaccin l'achat des vaccins par
l'établissement pharmaceutique donc par
santé publique de France nécessite un
budget très important mais qui est voilà
qui est fléchée sur l'achat alors des
vaccins et puis d'autres équipements
évidemment mais c'est effectivement les
vaccins qui sont
qui comptent pour beaucoup dans notre
dans notre budget
d'achat via l'établissement
pharmaceutique tu veux compléter
le budget supplémentaire qui nous a été
alloué et qui est effectivement très
important par rapport au moyen au moyen
pérenne n'a été utilisé que pour de la
gestion de menaces sanitaires
donc essentiellement comme l'indiqué
Caroline semaille sur la covid et puis
la variole du singe avec et ce budget là
permet outre l'acquisition des vaccins
qui est le coût principal également la
prise en charge de tous ceux qui est
coup de stockage et de distribution des
contre-mesures puisque à chaque fois que
l'établissement pharmaceutique achète un
produit c'est pour le mettre à
disposition de la population et de
répondre à une menace sanitaire donc
systématiquement il y a le coût associé
lié au stockage et à la distribution
mais cette enveloppe est d'ailleurs au
sein de notre budget
cette enveloppe est suivie de manière
spécifique avec un code analytique
spécifique qui permet de s'assurer en
termes de fléchage que les moyens sont
bien uniquement dévolus au sujet liés
aux menaces sanitaires graves auxquelles
nous devons faire face
alors après pour répondre et ça va
répondre un petit peu à vos questions
mais j'y reviendrai aux spécifiquement
disons 2 3 et 4 en termes de
notre rôle dans la pénurie il faut
peut-être aussi revenir sur de quoi on
dispose alors je ne peux pas vous
détailler les stocks qui sont dans
l'établissement pharmaceutique mais les
stocks c'est vraiment des stocks
stratégiques donc on dispose souvent de
produits qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
qu'on ne retrouve pas en fait en
pharmacie on a notamment des antidotes
je pense aux antitoxines diphthériques
aux antitoxines botuliques alors
pourquoi elles sont dans les stocks
stratégiques parce que d'une part c'est
une menace grave je veux dire la
diphtérie ou le botulisme et en plus
c'est des produits qui sont produits en
petite quantité pour lequel il faut une
mise à disposition extrêmement rapide
donc effectivement on dispose dans le
cas des stocks stratégiques de produits
comme ça on dit on dispose aussi des EPI
des masques de protection on dispose
d'antiviraux etc mais on ne dispose pas
de tous les médicaments qu'on trouve en
France on a
des produits et des stocks stratégiques
qui sont qui répondent à des menaces
sanitaires graves
ça c'est le premier point donc
notre rôle au niveau de santé publique
France n'est pas le on n'a pas un rôle
de suivi des pénuries c'est des un rôle
qui appartient plutôt à d'autres agences
quand je vous disais qu'on faisait
effectivement attention aux tensions
d'approvisionnement parce que on dispose
dans les stocks stratégiques de
médicaments qui sont souvent des on a
des produits en petites quantité qui
sont produits assez difficilement je
parlais des antidotes etc donc on est
effectivement très attentif à des
tensions en approvisionnement pour ces
produits là mais on n'a pas vocation à
suivre évidemment toutes les pénuries
des médicaments on n'est pas outillés
pour ça et d'autres agents sont bien
mieux outillés que nous pour faire cette
surveillance en tout cas sont plus
outillés que nous parce que le sont
suffisamment c'est peut-être une
question mais en tout cas elles le sont
plus outillées que nous que pour suivre
les tensions en approvisionnement
donc il y avait une autre question aussi
sur le fait de s'auto saisir sur le
stock stratégique alors
aujourd'hui effectivement il y a une
doctrine qui date de 2017 donc on voit
bien que il est important de réviser
cette doctrine le l'environnement et
l'écosystème a changé les enjeux sont de
plus en plus importants on l'a bien vu
et puis un RBC les changements
climatiques donc on a des enjeux
auxquels on va devoir faire face dans
les dans les années à venir on a eu
aussi évidemment cette pandémie covid
qui nous a permis de voir à quel point
et même la crise Ukraine à quel point il
peut y avoir des tensions mondiales dans
tout ce qui est fabrication même
transport logistique des produits donc
voilà il est vraiment important de ces
dernières années nous ont vraiment
montré comment la fabrication pouvait
être tendue et même la logistique
combien était complexe une distribution
des produits donc on a aussi besoin de
prendre en compte ça et d'autre part
effectivement l'écosystème un peu changé
l'Europe a pris et vous l'avez cité une
place beaucoup le plus importantes et je
pense notamment à la création de
era en septembre 2021 donc contenu de
ces enjeux qui ne vont faire
qu'augmenter toutes ces dernières années
le rétex covid la crise Ukraine les
problématiques de pénurie de fabrication
de logistique et le contexte européen
fait que effectivement la doctrine de
2017 il est important de la revoir donc
nous sommes associés à cette
à cette réflexion mais pas seulement
nous je l'ai cité dans mon propos
liminaire il y a évidemment le Haut
Conseil de la santé publique qui est
sollicitée pour tout ce qui risque
infectieux environnementaux
je suppose que vous les avez d'ailleurs
auditionnés l'IRSN la SN sur tout ce qui
est protection des populations en cas
d'accident nucléaire et menaces
radiologique lande cesse l'INERIS etc
donc voilà et en termes d'auto saisie
nous avait effectivement la Cour des
comptes s'est prononcé en faveur de
duauto saisine donc même si je viens de
citer que nous sommes partis prenantes
dans tout ce qui est élaboration de la
doctrine bien entendu ça se fait pas on
n'est pas en marge de cette élaboration
mais nous ne sommes pas du tout
effectivement opposés à une auto saisine
je l'ai dit dans le cadre de mes
auditions parlementaires à une sorte de
d'auto saisine et faut qu'on voit dans
quel cadre mais nous ne sommes pas
opposés comme la souligner la Cour des
comptes à une auto-césine de de santé
publique France même si de toute façon
dans le cadre des relations
nous sommes force de proposition auprès
du ministère de la santé mais un point
important on l'a souligné
l'établissement pharmaceutique le nombre
de personnes qui sont à l'établissement
pharmaceutique et assez faible au
demeurant par rapport à la mission on a
évidemment besoin de moyens adéquats à
la fois budgétaire et en ressources
humaines et vous savez que nous sommes
nous avons un plafond d'emploi qui fait
que nous avons pas une flexibilité comme
les autres agences d'ailleurs c'est pas
spécifique à santé publique France
donc voilà donc sur les suivis des
médicaments je pense que j'y ai répondu
sur tout ce qui est Europe le contexte
écosystème européen je veux peut-être
laisser Stéphane compléter parce que
nous avons des relations avec Héra mais
je te laisse compléter on est parti
prenante de pas mal de groupes
évidemment au niveau européen à la fois
la vase de riforum et aussi
au niveau RH de la sauce Stéphane
compléter
merci alors effectivement
on suit avec beaucoup d'attention ce qui
se passe au niveau européen on suit et
puis on est aussi un acteur puisque
santé publique France
vis-à-vis de rats et membre de la vie
soriforme
la devise forum dans la gouvernance le
forum qui
consultatif consultatif
ou qui associe
le forum consultatif l'organe l'instance
qui associe l'ensemble des États membres
à la gouvernance
et qui associe en plus des États membres
la société civile et également les
grands acteurs du de l'écosystème en
matière de médicaments et de
contre-mesure donc c'est un organisme
qui est consultatif mais qui permet
d'échanger justement de manière assez
informelle sur les perspectives les
évolutions thérapeutiques possibles etc
donc on est destinataire bien évidemment
de l'ensemble des documents
préparatoires on y contribue également à
réagissant sur ces documents donc il y a
des interactions qui se font à ce niveau
là donc ça ça permet un suivi on va dire
général de l'activité au niveau européen
et ça nous permet également de mieux
articuler notre action nationale
vis-à-vis des initiatives européennes et
éventuellement aussi de participer à des
programmes et d'obtenir des financements
dans ce cadre là et puis il y a à côté
de ce premier assez général en termes
d'activité
il y a un deuxième élément qui est
beaucoup plus pratique et opérationnel
pour l'établissement pharmaceutique et
santé publique France c'est que era
lance un certain nombre de procédures au
niveau européen au cas des États membres
peuvent souscrire pour acheter des
contre-mesures de manière de manière
groupée et bien évidemment nous
participons également à chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire et pertinent à ces
procédures pour donner un seul exemple
sans rentrer dans les détails des
contrats concernés
on parle du risque de pandémie grippal
notamment lié à un risque zoo nautique
et d'une transmission à l'homme dans ce
cadre de l'anticipation le niveau
européen a proposé des marchés de
réservation de capacité de production de
vaccins pandémique
auxquels nous avons souscrit
et donc cette action cet articulation
peut se faire soit en substitution c'est
à dire qu'on on achète uniquement au
travers de l'instrument européen qui
nous est proposé ou alors en complément
parce qu'en fonction de la quantité de
la contre-mesure dont nous devons
disposer au niveau national si
l'instrument européen ne permet pas
d'avoir la totalité de cette quantité
nous complétons par un marché national
voilà les deux grands pans d'action que
nous pouvons avoir sur sur le sujet
c'est effectivement ce que je disais
dans ma propre polymère on n'a pas
forcément toujours des stocks physiques
on a aussi des stocks en fait réservés
qui sont pas forcément physiquement
physiquement sur nos plateformes parce
que comme je disais on n'a pas on a une
plateforme nationale on a des opérateurs
privés pour des plateformes régionales
on n'a pas non plus une capacité de
stockage infini en tout cas elle est
très très réduite à côté de ce dont
dispose les opérateurs privés qui je
vous laisse pour être sûr d'avoir mis un
compris par exemple sur l'exemple qui
qui vient de nous est donné on peut dire
que en fait ce sont des précommandes
avec era là c'est ça ou je non en fait
on s'engage
à réserver une capacité de production
qui permet de produire x millions de
vaccins dans un temps déterminé dans le
contrat et donc chaque année nous
rémunérons l'entreprise enfin le
fabricant pour la capacité de de
production qui nous met ainsi à
disposition de manière permanente et qui
donc n'utilisent pas pour autre chose
au cours de l'année et si le risque
venait à se vérifier et que nous devions
donc lancer effectivement la production
du vaccin nous achèterions ensuite à un
prix qui est déjà négocié au préalable
dans le contrat les dix vaccins mais le
principal intérêt outre le fait que ça a
économise entre guillemets des capacités
de stockage
la principale intérêt d'une telle
procédure c'est qu'en fait comme le
risque pandémique par définition on ne
sait pas quelle est la souche du virus
qui serait concernés le fait d'avoir une
capacité de réservation permet d'avoir
un vaccin produit
sur la base de la souche en circulation
au moment où on en a besoin et donc
d'avoir la contre-mesure la plus adaptée
à la menace à un instant T
alors après vous avez demandé enfin sur
la gestion des pénuries c'est vrai que
j'ai un petit peu répondu dans mes
propos liminaires c'est vrai que nous
nous sommes mobilisa vraiment en cas de
menace sanitaire grave c'est vrai qu'on
ne peut pas non plus se substituer aux
obligations des industriels qui doivent
disposer d'un stock minimal de sécurité
de deux mois et qui d'ailleurs peut être
plus que deux mois dans certaines
circonstances ou moins deux mois dans
d'autres circonstances pour tous les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs d'autant que notre logistique
pharmaceutique comme je le dis ne peut
pas du tout ni ce substitue à ce qui
existe aujourd'hui et n'a de toute façon
pas la même force de frappe que ce qu'il
y a aujourd'hui
ce dont dispose les industriels c'est
vrai que on a beaucoup un circuit
logistique on la mobilisé pour les
vaccins covid ce qui était un peu
exceptionnel et ce qui est d'ailleurs
pas facile pour les vaccins covid et les
vaccins manquaient pas que son est allé
jusqu'au niveau officine mais
habituellement je dirais les stocks
stratégiques quand on les libère de nos
établissements enfin de nos plateformes
ils vont dans les établissements
pharmaceutiques dans les établissements
de santé donc principalement nos acteurs
naturels sont plus les établissements de
santé mais on sait on s'est adapté et
dans le cas du vaccin covid et mon K-pop
on s'est adapté pour aller jusqu'au
niveau officinal mais voilà c'est
quelque chose de quand même un peu plus
complexe naturellement on travaille avec
les établissements de santé complète
peut-être sur ce point-là aussi
en matière en matière logistique
donc on a une seule plateforme qui nous
appartient en propre avec là aussi un
effectif permanent qui est ce qu'il est
c'est à dire assez assez réduit trois
ETP en permanence sur sur le site de la
plateforme nationale 3
et ensuite donc nous avons des
plateformes zonales et des plateformes à
compétences nationales prestataires
privés donc qui eux fournissent une
prestation de stockage
et de distribution également dans une
aire géographique prédéfinie
et nous avons également des contrats
avec des contrats ayant pour but
uniquement le transport pour renforcer
et offrir une sécurité supplémentaire
par rapport aux moyens de nos
plateformes logistiques donc on s'est
créé en quelque sorte aussi un filet de
sécurité en ayant des contrats de
transport seuls permettant de venir en
appui des capacités logistiques de nos
prestataires sur les plateformes parce
que on nous parlions
fort justement de tension sur le
certains médicaments mais il y a aussi
une tension sur la logistique et le
secteur de la logistique sur la capacité
à disposer de camions de chauffeurs ça
peut paraître très pratiques aux
pratiques mais c'est notre c'est notre
quotidien parce que si on ne s'assure
pas et on ne garantit pas cette
disponibilité finalement le fait d'avoir
certains produits en stock seraient
complètement inopérant si nous étions
dans l'incapacité ensuite de pouvoir les
sortir de nos de nos plateformes et ça
aussi un de nos sujets on a bien vu avec
la crise covid et dans une moindre
mesure ensuite avec la variole du singe
qu'on touchait en quelque sorte les
limites d'un système logistique qui est
en tension par manque de ressources
également humaines difficultés de
recrutement dans le secteur ou
disponibilité de certains vecteurs
terrestres sachant qu'on a
essentiellement du vecteur terrestre
mais on a également des contrats qui
nous permet notamment pour rapporter un
soutien rapide à nos outre-mer en plus
de nos plateformes qui sont déjà situées
de faire du transport aérien
et ou du transport maritime en fonction
de l'urgence de livraison des produits
ou des volumétrie ou de l'incapacité à
faire
embarquer certains produits par des
avions pour des raisons de sécurité donc
il y a véritablement ces deux volets qui
sont essentiels pour maintenir le
caractère opérationnel de nos stocks
c'est important effectivement de noter
qu'on est mobilisable vraiment 24 heures
sur 24 séjour sur 7 je pense très
régulièrement en astreinte on peut être
appelé pour un cas de botulisme dans un
établissement de santé et donc très
rapidement il faut envoyer les
antidoxines botulique au niveau de
l'établissement de santé et donc ça ça
arrive pour la diphtérie quasiment enfin
très très régulièrement donc c'est vrai
qu'on voit bien qu'on a une logistique
avec pour des vaccins covid au monde
kpops très très large où là il faut
aller un peu partout en outre-mer au
niveau des officines etc et puis réagir
très très vite une cinétique extrêmement
on a vraiment des cinétiques qui peuvent
être longues ou dessiner extrêmement
courtes où il faut libérer en quelques
heures une antitoxine pour aller soigner
impatient dans un établissement de santé
spécifique donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
tout ça aussi qui est enfin voilà il
faut jongler entre ces cinétiques
courtes et ces cinétiques longues
merci beaucoup Bruno Belin
merci madame le Président d'abord merci
pour votre présentation Madame et
Monsieur pour les éléments que vous avez
apporté en complément alors ça on est
bien d'accord que le cas covid variole
du singe ou même celui du modulisme que
vous évoquez sont des cas exceptionnels
dans leur vraie définition
mais on a bien vu cet hiver 2022 2023 la
réalité
officinale partout en France ça a été
des manques aussi simples que
l'amoxicilline la prennent l'isolone
c'est-à-dire des corticoïdes et ou des
antibiotiques qui ont 60 ans d'existence
puisque vous avez ces stocks et
j'imagine bien que vous avez des stocks
de corticoïdes
quelque part à quel moment ou pourquoi
ou comment pourrions-nous les mettre à
disposition de répartiteur qui ont les
moyens logistiques d'aller partout en
France et qui ont les moyens et Dieu
sait qu'il faut qu'on les sacralise si
on veut respecter cette égalité
qu'elle n'entend dans cette mission et à
la règle d'aménagement du territoire
comment pouvons-nous faire pour mettre
vos stocks à disposition du réseau
officinal sur le terrain et ainsi à
disposition des patients
alors déjà effectivement
pardon à laisser
le président de merci pour votre
présentation qui est le mérite
effectivement d'être très clair et vous
avez vraiment un rôle effectivement qui
est très spécifique les crises menaces
graves on a bien compris cela moi
j'avais juste un petit question de
détails sur votre organisation la grande
plateforme vous avez trois et TP et
ensuite vous dites vous avez donc des
contrats de transport et des plateformes
privées
ça fait partie de votre budget vous êtes
vous les rémunéré
est-ce que ce serait pas plus
intéressant d'avoir des plateformes
délocalisées mais publiques plutôt que
de d'avoir à faire au privé c'est juste
une question
du coup je vais compléter sur cette
fameuse plateforme je suppose que les
plateformes zonales sont celles qui
avaient été utilisées pour la
distribution des vaccins RN messagers
covid il y en avait quatre ou cinq en
France me semble-t-il donc c'est juste
pour avoir des éléments de de précision
donc c'était des plateformes qui avaient
pas d'énormes capacités de stockage
parce qu'en plus les boîtes à pizza des
vaccins prenez peu de place voilà donc
je pense que les plateformes zonales
restent limitées en tout cas elles
peuvent pas répondre à cet objectif de
stockage
de cette fameuse liste en cours de en
cours de rédaction de
médicaments dit critique
qui se trouve aux alentours de 152 ans
donc ça ça c'est un vrai sujet donc
est-ce que est-ce que
comment vous voyez la capacité à
démultiplier le stockage si c'était
nécessaire parce que ça peut être une
urgence de manquer d'antibiotiques voilà
c'est voilà quand il y a 8 quand il y en
a plus c'est on est dans une situation
sanitaire d'urgence et là en
l'occurrence
on n'est pas loin d'être dans cette
situation parce que la pénurie
d'amoxicilline a été compensée par
d'autres antibiotiques et on est en
situation de pénurie large
d'antibiotiques sur plusieurs classes
thérapeutiques donc voilà donc jusqu'où
jusqu'où ou commence et au finit
l'urgence voilà c'est je sais bien que
c'est pas un élément si simple que ça
mais ça peut pas être que NRBC voilà
c'est c'est il y a des effets de bord
voilà et quel est votre point de vue sur
ce sujet et donc du coup comment
pourriez-vous vous intégrer dans cette
question de la gestion de la pénurie de
médicaments
en France
Madeleine question porte sur un sujet
purement organisationnel vous avez une
connaissance assez large de pas mal la
distance et institution en France en
charge des questions de médicaments et
de santé publique
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas à un
moment ou un autre que il faudrait qu'il
y ait un pilote ou au moins une
simplification
dans le sens diminution quantitative des
interlocuteurs et des intervenants c'est
pas l'émission qu'on diminue c'est
peut-être des regroupements effectifs ou
opérationnels vous nous dites à juste
titre que vous êtes en lien avec la NSM
avec la Direction générale de la santé
j'imagine un peu avec le CEPS quand même
de temps en temps et d'autres d'autres
institutions et instance officiel voilà
cette réflexion elle se
elle elle devient comment dire de plus
en plus importante parce que les
reproches sont nombreux depuis le début
de ces auditions dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête
d'une difficulté à trouver un pilote et
il semblerait que pendant la crise covid
le pilote ça a été quand même un petit
peu santé publique France mais peut-être
que je me trompe
et donc dernière question vous traitez
la question épidémiologique
qui dit épidémiologie dit suivi donc
l'épidémiologie c'est aussi le suivi des
pénuries parce que c'est le suivi des
pathologies résurgentes ou en
augmentation par défaut de traitement et
c'est une des conséquences des des
pénuries et en réalité en France on a un
petit sujet en matière d'épidémiologie
c'est que on a des données
épidémiologiques incomplètes imparfaite
pas toujours consolidé et pas toujours
vérifiable ou vérifier avec des
fournisseurs de données qui sont pas
toujours complètement
comment dire complaisant et donc je
j'imagine que vous êtes aussi dans un
travail de fond sur l'évolution des
contenus et des contenants du elfatoweb
qui est l'outil qui a été mis en place
en parallèle de vous pour pouvoir jouer
ce rôle épidémiologique et en matière de
suivi des pénuries de médicaments
on ne peut pas s'appuyer uniquement sur
la NSM et puis phare puisqu'on est
plutôt sur des remontées partielles du
territoire et on n'est pas sur des
remontées globales je vous remercie
alors donc je vais essayer de reprendre
plusieurs des questions sur
sur le personnel sur je te laisserai
répondre sur les plateformes régionales
donc déjà sur sur les antibiotiques
effectivement on a été face cet hiver
j'étais à la NSM avant donc je suis bien
placé pour le savoir sur amoxicilline
alors mais vous avez auditionné la NSM
je suppose voilà donc il vous a dit
aussi le nombre de pénuries qui suivait
le nombre de dossiers qui étaient suivis
et donc voilà
donc
encore une fois le stock stratégique il
ne dispose pas de tout et pas déjà une
dispose pas de tous les produits et
surtout des produits je dirais de
d'utilisation courant etc ils dispose
d'un certain nombre de produits d'une
part pas de tout et d'autre part pas non
plus en quantité énorme enfin je veux
dire c'est pas on n'est pas on ne stocke
pas dans les plateformes à la fois
nationale et au niveau régional d'un
nombre de médicaments qui soient
capables en fait de répondre aux besoins
de la population au quotidien voilà ça
c'est pas possible on n'a pas ni la
capacité d'achat de stockage et c'est
pas dans nos missions puisqu'on est
vraiment sur des mesures des menaces
sanitaires graves
corticoïdes je suis même pas certaines
qu'on en est beaucoup en stock peut-être
dans les mâles stock tactiques mais il
est pas certain du tout qu'on est en
tout cas des stocks de corticoïdes dans
les au niveau des plateformes
dans priori non c'est ça on en a dans
les stocks tactiques je pense qu'il y a
quelques produits enfin il y a des
produits nécessaires courante qui sont
qui sont dans les dans les stocks
tactiques donc ça c'est le premier point
on ne dispose pardon
effectivement les stocks tactiques sont
gérés par les amissements
de santé
oui c'est ce que j'ai précisé
effectivement c'est vraiment les
établissements de santé
donc d'une part on dispose pas du tout
et d'autre part on a parlé des pénuries
en fait les pénuries n'ont pas touché
que la France les pénuries en matière
d'amoxicilline ont touché en fait
l'Europe entière donc c'est pas une
spécificité française c'est vraiment le
problématique de pénurie elle touche
tous les pays
donc voilà donc on n'a pas la
possibilité nous de stocker
en fait à la fois les besoins en
antibiotiques de toute la population
française
on peut stocker des médicaments ou des
antibiotiques qui sont absolument
nécessaires dans le cadre de menaces
sanitaire graves je pense tout ce qui
risque énervécé je pense notamment aux
fluoroquinolone qui sont absolument
nécessaires et qui doivent être
mobilisés rapidement
voilà donc ça c'est le premier point
et d'autre part les causes de pénurie
sont extrêmement variables ça peut être
aussi un problème de fabrication de
matière première etc et comme je le
disais en introduction on n'a pas les
moyens effectivement de fabriquer au
niveau de l'établissement pharmaceutique
en tout cas aujourd'hui on a absolument
pas les moyens
après de faire vous avez cité la
probabilité de la possibilité de faire
des stocks mais c'est ce que je citais
aussi dans les propos liminaires si par
exemple là au moment d'une tension si
l'état commence à acheter et faire des
stocks on va aussi déstabiliser le
marché donc il faut faire très très
attention à ne pas déstabiliser un
marché qui d'ailleurs est déstabilisé
pas seulement en France mais un peu
partout en Europe donc créer des stocks
est aussi une problématique il faut bien
avoir conscience de au moment où il y a
déjà une tension voire une pénurie créer
un stock à ce moment là peut en plus
déstabiliser encore plus le marché après
créer des stocks très en amont
et ben ça aussi pose la problématique de
la péremption des stocks qu'il faut
éventuellement surveiller modifier etc
puis c'est d'avoir éventuellement des
stocks d'amoxicilline et puis il y a une
péremption et on les a pas utilisés donc
on va les détruire ou les remettre dans
le circuit classique juste avant la
péremption pour qu'il ne soit pas
détruit etc donc ça c'est ce qui a été
fait d'ailleurs pour certaines certains
produits Stéphane mais pour les cureurs
et tu peux peut-être détailler ça vous
avez cité aussi le CEPS alors le CEPS
effectivement est chargé du prix nous
nous n'intervons pas d'intervenons pas
spécialement au niveau du prix des
médicaments mais effectivement on a dû
vous l'exposer lors de toutes les
auditions en tout cas j'imagine les
industriels que le prix du médicament
est effectivement certainement la
question c'est ce que vous ayez pas vous
faisiez partie des membres consultés par
le CEPS au même titre que la CNAM la NSM
la chas voilà alors direction générale
de la santé comme ça fait seulement un
mois un plus fin février je ne pense que
non mais comme je ne suis pas je vais me
tourner mais je ne pense pas qu'on soit
consulté dans le cadre du CEPS nous
pourrons vous le confirmer mais a priori
non nous ne sommes pas consultés
pourtant vous avez un rôle de veille
sanitaire ça pourrait quand même avoir
un intérêt en matière de politique du
prix du médicament
c'est vrai que le CEPS s'appuie aussi
sur les données de la Haute Autorité de
Santé et nous sommes aussi partis
prenant de certains groupes de la Haute
Autorité de santé qui peut aussi nous
auditionner ou nous consulter autant que
faire ce
vais aussi des questions sur comment on
peut nos plateformes régionales comment
voilà elles sont aujourd'hui privées
comment c'est un état de fait ce que il
y a des possibilités de de voir les
choses autrement
sur nos plateformes en fait
en termes de fonctionnement courant je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait une grande
différence entre une plateforme public
et une plateforme privée à partir du
moment où les plateformes privées sont
sélectionnés sur la base d'un cahier des
charges qui est extrêmement rigoureux
avec des
des règles très précises indiquées
notamment en termes d'astreinte de
disponibilité de sécurité des locaux
parce qu'il y a aussi comme on est sur
des stocks stratégiques le sujet de la
sécurité des locaux pour éviter que des
actes malveillants puissent mettre aussi
en péril la sauvegarde de nos stocks
donc de ce point de vue là il n'y a pas
de différence
pratique entre le fait d'avoir une
structure publique ou une structure
privée
alors sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
financier bien évidemment on rémunère
ces prestataires
ces prestataires sont rémunérés sur la
base de marché sur laquelle nous nous
engageons sur des minimum contractuels
et ça aussi comme vertu de pouvoir
adapter en fait le niveau que l'on
demande de stockage à nos plateformes en
fonction de notre activité réelle alors
que avoir des structures qui soient par
exemple des structures publiques
dimensionnées sur
l'épisode le plus important
veut dire que en situation de moindre
tension nous aurions une surcapacité de
stockage et des infrastructures qui ne
seraient pas complètement adapté et puis
nos appels d'offres permettent d'avoir
une mise en concurrence entre des
prestataires différents et donc on est
bien évidemment pas sur le moins 10 ans
parce que c'est pas la logique qui
recherchait
on recherche l'offre qui est la
meilleure à la fois d'un point de vue
fonctionnel notamment sur un point de
vue fonctionnel mais du coup il y a
aussi du fait de la concurrence sur la
tarification il y a des éléments qui
peuvent qui peuvent être intéressants
oui sur les conditions de sécurité que
j'ai indiquées qui font partie du cahier
des charges de même que dans le cahier
des charges par exemple on demande à ce
que l'opérateur est un Plan de
Continuité d'Activité
qu'il soit existant à jour pour nous
donner aussi une assurance raisonnable
qu'en cas de difficultés ce Plan de
Continuité d'Activité puisse permettre
la poursuite des activités de déstockage
ou de réception de réception des
produits
sur leur nombre et leur positionnement
le schéma directeur initial de santé
publique France était d'avoir une
plateforme nationale en propre et des
plateformes dans une plateforme dans
chaque zone de défense et de sécurité si
je mets de côté le cas spécifique de
l'outre-mer où on a mis en place des
plateformes de dite de proximité
ce schéma là est adapté était adapté à
un stock stratégique au sens premier du
terme c'est à dire limiter un certain
nombre de menaces essentiellement
énervécé les plans gouvernementaux
la crise covid a montré que ce réseau là
n'était pas suffisant pour répondre à
une menace sanitaire qui nécessitait
d'aller très très près du citoyen en
termes de délivrance des contre-mesures
et en termes de stockage
donc pendant la crise sanitaire on est
allé jusqu'à créer 13 plateformes
supplémentaires
pour
augmenter les capacités de stockage et à
partir de ces plateformes démultiplier
des points de livraison des
contre-mesures
ensuite avec la baisse
une relative comment dire relative
accalmie sur le front de l'épidémie de
la covid on a pu revenir un système où
nous avons réduit ce nombre de
plateformes temporaires
à 5 plateformes à compétences nationales
deux plateformes plus centrées sur les
EPI et les masques notamment et trois
plateformes que l'on appelle dans notre
langage nos dépositaires sur la partie
vaccination
et dans la réflexion qui évoquée
Caroline semaï dans son propos
introductif sur la doctrine des struques
stratégiques il y aura bien évidemment à
re questionner le schéma directeur en
termes de plateforme de savoir si on
pérennise ces plateformes à compétences
nationales ou est-ce qu'on change ou
est-ce qu'on change de modèle
au-delà de ces capacités en termes de
nombre de plateformes la spécificité
également de la crise covid
a été dans la prise en charge de
produits qui avaient des
caractéristiques très spécifiques
notamment en termes de conservation je
pense notamment à certains vaccins à RN
messager qui nécessitait une
conservation à moins 80 degrés
voilà qui est une conservation dont on
avait assez peu la pratique au sein de
l'établissement pharmaceutique même si
nous avions quelques produits déjà
concernés par de tels de telles
températures mais en tout cas sur des
produits en quantité bien moindre que
celle dont nous avions le besoin pour
pour la covid en tout cas nos
prestataires
que ce soit les dépositaires ou les
grossistes répartiteurs surtout
notamment les grossistes répartiteurs
n'ont pas la pratique de cette
température à -80 donc il a fallu aussi
adapter nos infrastructures c'est à dire
acheter
de nouvelles capacités de stockage à
moins 80 c'est à décongélateur
avec un marché également tendu parce que
peu de fournisseurs
et donc pour répondre aussi à une
question qui était sous-jacente tout à
l'heure il nous faut bien évidemment
anticiper c'est-à-dire qu'on essaye de
donner une visibilité sur nos besoins
à nos fournisseurs qui ne soient pas non
plus une visibilité uniquement liée à
quelques mois voire à l'année pour qu'il
puisse nous assurer d'une disponibilité
de ces produits après on touche la
limite mais que vous connaissez bien au
sein de cette institution entre
l'articulation entre un budget qui reste
essentiellement annuel
mais insérer dans des perspectives
pluriannuelles ou la plurianualité donne
finalement une perspective à l'ensemble
des acteurs et des opérateurs pour
planifier leurs opérations investir dans
nous de nouvelles capacités
et au-delà de la
du besoin d'acheter de nouvelles
capacités de stockage en froid à moins
comme ce sont des ressources très
spécifiques qui nécessitent des besoins
énergétiques aussi importants ça veut
dire derrière
adapter
les circuits et adaptés et adapter tous
les circuits électriques toutes les
infrastructures électriques ce qui
représente des travaux importants mais
qui sont aussi des investissements pour
l'avenir puisque
le -80 peut être une température
désormais
utile pour un certain nombre de
contre-mesures donc voilà quelques
éléments pour répondre aux différentes
questions sur sur les plateformes alors
effectivement on voit bien que santé
publique France a montré sa capacité
d'adaptation face à ce défi on voit bien
en termes logistique d'achat de matériel
etc ça a été un défi qui a été relevé
par une équipe qui est pas si importante
que ça qui donc voilà aujourd'hui on
aurait besoin d'être renforcé
peut-être vous avez posé une question et
je suis pas sûre peut-être que je vais
vous demander de me faire préciser un
peu sur le fait ne dispose pas de donner
épidémiologiques fiables et ce que vous
entendez par là de donner
épidémiologiques de donner sur la
consommation des médicaments des
antibiotiques ou des données épidémiques
sur la prévalence de pathologies c'était
là j'étais pas sûr de
c'est un tout
c'est un tout c'est à dire que les
données du CNDS sont partiels
elles sont partielles c'est donner du
CNDS donc on n'a pas l'étendue complète
des pathologies
epif art fonctionne sur des des signaux
et
des sons il faut qu'il y ait quand même
un nombre de cas suffisant
pour que le signal soit
entendu quoi sur le plan épidémiologique
et donc c'est c'est
et je vais terminer en ce qui concerne
les pénuries de médicaments on nous a
témoigné plusieurs fois que finalement
faute d'avoir des données complètes
c'est parfois par les signaux
épidémiologiques on se rend compte qu'il
manque des pays médicaments ou parce
qu'ils appellent les
interlocuteurs les signaux faibles c'est
à dire qu'il y a une résurgence d'une
pathologie on se dit tiens là on va
manquer de médicaments
[Musique]
mis en place des mesures de prévention
auprès des sites auprès des flyers etc
et puis utiliser les les traitements qui
étaient à l'établissement pharmaceutique
où on est un des rares pays en fait en
Europe avec le UK à avoir pu avoir pu
mettre à disposition très vite la
vaccination en fait vis-à-vis de la on a
utilisé les vaccins variole pour pour la
variole du singe pour le manque donc
voilà donc je pense pas qu'on puisse
dire qu'en dispose pas de donner
épidémiologiques pas fiables on essaye
de mettre en place le plus possible de
détection précoce des épidémies et on le
fait pas seul au niveau national parce
que on le voit bien même par exemple si
je pense aux
toutes ces infections invasives graves
streptocoque A qui a aussi qui est
survenu au dernier trimestre au dernier
semestre 2022 en fait on l'a perçu en
France on l'a observé en France mais on
l'avait aussi dans les autres États
membres donc on voit bien voilà que on
l'a mis en évidence au niveau français
et d'autres pays peuvent nous alerter
s'ils sont alertés avant ils nous
alertent et après on recherche les
recherches on met en place des systèmes
particuliers donc je pense qu'on peut
pas dire comme qu'on a des données pas
fiables on peut toujours améliorer c'est
vrai mais on dispose quand même de d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui nous
permettent d'alerter assez rapidement
peut-être de de précisions parce que
quand on va sur le site donc
de votre agence si par exemple on tape
des des mots clés etc il n'y a pas
il y a pas le le résultat sur pénurie de
médicament or vous êtes or ce que vous
nous avez dit
dans tous vos propos c'est que vous vous
n'êtes pas loin sans faut indifférent à
ces pénuries à ces tensions etc donc
comment se fait-il que sur le site il
n'y est pas
cette enfin cette référence qui
conduirait à effectivement voir ce que
vous ce que vous faites ça c'est ma
première question et puis j'ai un
sentiment c'est à dire qu'à la fois vous
avez des missions qui sont extrêmement
importantes que vous avez détaillées
mais le sentiment que j'ai au fil des
auditions c'est que j'ai un peu le
sentiment que plusieurs agences
s'occupent de la même chose et qu'il y a
un peu un manque de coordination
pour le dire plus directement il y a un
peu un risque de ce marché sur les pieds
quoi et c'est ça peut entraîner du coup
moi d'efficacité moins de rapidité etc
alors peut-être que non ou qui est au
cœur de votre agence mais parfois il y a
quand même
ce sentiment là en tous les cas merci
d'avance
alors effectivement je pense que le mot
pénurie sur le site de la NSM est
beaucoup plus présent puisque ils ont
mis en place des systèmes réglementaires
etc et qui suivent et qui sont en
contact avec les industriels vous vous
avez remarqué les missions extrêmement
large déjà de santé publique France qui
sont vraiment la protection de la
population etc donc quand j'ai parlé de
pénurie et qu'on était sensible aux
histoires de tension c'était on était
très attentif aux problématiques de
tension pour ce qui concerne les
produits qui sont dans nos stock
stratégique parce que on a effectivement
nous dans le stock stratégiques vraiment
des produits pour lequel souvent la
production est difficile
et donc c'est là dessus je pense
vraiment aux antidotes on sait que
souvent c'est des monopres il s'agit de
monopole donc c'est là où je dirais que
nous on a une intention très
particulière c'est les produits qui sont
dans le stock stratégique pour lequel on
sait qu'il peut y avoir des problèmes de
production donc c'est pas effectivement
l'ensemble des enfin il y a des milliers
et des milliers de médicaments et de
produits santé parce que si je vais
jusqu'au dispositif médicaux là on est
sur quelque chose très large mais c'est
vrai que nous on est quand même pas sur
on regarde pas l'ensemble des produits
on ne regarde enfin ce qui nous
intéresse en premier lieu parce que la
NSA est là pour regarder le reste du
marché nous c'est vraiment le stock
stratégique et on sait qu'effectivement
au sein du socle on a des produits pour
lequel il peut y avoir des problèmes
types de tension souvent parce que c'est
des produits rares peut utiliser on a
cité que les pénuries touchés des vieux
produits pas chers mais voilà nous on
est sur des dans le 5 stratégique il y a
des produits pour lequel la production
est faible elle n'intéresse pas
énormément les grands industriels et
d'ailleurs c'est une des problématiques
que j'ai signé signalé dans le mes
propos liminaire souvent on a des
antidotes qui sont vraiment en situation
de monopole et ça c'est effectivement
une problématique ça n'intéresse pas
beaucoup l'industrie pharmaceutique sauf
quelques rares
petites entreprises pour lequel voilà il
faut vraiment que on sécurise cette
approvisionnement donc oui on ne regarde
pas l'ensemble on est vraiment nous sur
les médicaments du stock
sur le stock stratégique alors je pense
que je ne peux pas effectivement
complètement mais je pense que vous avez
moyen je peux pas en audition publique
vous donner exactement le nombre de
produits mais en revanche je pense que
vous pouvez tout à fait nous faire la
demande et on trouvera un moyen de vous
donner cette information mais comme vous
m'avez indiquez c'est une audition
publique il s'agit de stock stratégique
etc donc je peux voilà mais oui tout à
fait c'est évidemment cette formation
est disponible et on pourra vous la
mettre à disposition et on trouvera un
moyen de vous la mettre à disposition
en termes de coordination c'est vrai que
sur ce sujet là je ne vois pas de
d'OVERLAP enfin ou de d'interse je pense
que justement chacun chacune des agences
et des institutions on a bien notre rôle
c'est à dire que la NSM effectivement
est suit est en contact direct avec les
industriels quand il y a une pénurie va
chercher à importer à trouver une autre
forme etc
nous on travaille évidemment avec la NSM
parce que quand on doit chercher des
contre-mesures quand on fait la
cartographie des contre mesures
disponibles bien entendu on s'adresse à
la NSM qui est la mieux placée pour nous
dire oui en termes de efficacité
sécurité etc ça te contre-mesure elle
est efficace elle est sécuritaire et on
vous alerte sur le fait que peut-être il
y a un problème de production parce que
ils ont évidemment au niveau de la NSM
une vision du marché enfin en tout cas
du paysage industriel bien supérieur à
une autre donc on est beaucoup
effectivement en relation avec un essai
mais puis effectivement étant non une
ancienne directrice générale adjointe de
la NSM je suis particulièrement sensible
à tout ça donc oui on travaille vraiment
main dans la main avec la NSM là dessus
et aussi dans tout ce qui est
cartographies des risques sanitaires le
ministère de la Santé s'appuie sur le
Haut conseil de santé publique s'appuie
sur l'IRSN l'encens les nerises etc et
ce sont nos partenaires naturels aussi
et voilà je pense que
en tout cas en ce qui concerne nous la
constitution des stocks stratégiques je
trouve que la répartition des rôles est
correcte après le considérer qu'on peut
avoir plus de moyens c'est vrai plus de
moyens à la fois budgétaires et humains
mais je pense que la cartographie est
relativement claire entre les
différentes entités
et il existe en ce qui concerne la
pénurie une feuille de route mais ça je
imagine que ce n'est pas à moi d'en
parler mais vous avez eu
aussi voilà donc je pense que sur ce
sujet là il n'y a pas trop de je pense
que la répartition des rôles est tout à
fait adéquate
merci beaucoup juste une petite question
quel est l'effectif de santé
publiquement ce qu'on vient de TP
alors comme j'ai juré faut que je donne
le chiffre exact alors c'est 700 je dis
toujours 750 plus les CDD alors je me
permettrai de revenir vers vous avec le
chiffre exact parce que globalement on
est à peu près 750 mais évidemment on a
en fonction des années des CDD et qui
viennent des renforts covides qui vont
d'ailleurs plus rester présent donc
c'est d'ailleurs une on a des renforts
au niveau de l'établissement
pharmaceutique qui sont importants mais
voilà on n'est pas certain de pouvoir
les garder donc je me permettrais de
revenir vers vous avec des chiffres
exacts parce que je pense que c'est
important
très bien mais merci beaucoup pour tous
ces tous ces éléments
donc je lève la séance et vous rappeler
que nous nous retrouvons le mardi 2 mai
à 9h pour l'audition de Madame le
Ministre Rosine Bachelot ancienne
ministre de la Santé